Over the past several years, generative AI has moved into the classroom at lightning speed. Students are using AI to brainstorm ideas, write papers, solve math problems, and study for exams. Teachers are experimenting with it to create lesson plans and develop assignments. Meanwhile, schools and universities are trying to adapt to a technology that is evolving faster than many policies and teaching practices can keep up. Today we're going to talk to two experts who are helping educators navigate these changes using the science of learning to help answer questions about how AI can support and not hinder student learning. So how are students using AI in their work right now? What counts as cheating in the age of AI? What kinds of assignments, projects, and exams can teachers use to make sure that their
在过去几年里，生成式人工智能以闪电般的速度进入了课堂。学生们正在利用人工智能来激发创意、撰写论文、解决数学问题以及备考。教师们也在尝试利用它来制定教案和开发作业。与此同时，学校和大学正试图适应一种比许多政策和教学实践发展速度更快的技术。今天，我们将与两位专家交谈，他们正在利用学习科学帮助教育工作者应对这些变化，以解答关于人工智能如何支持而非阻碍学生学习的问题。那么，学生们目前在学习中是如何使用人工智能的呢？在人工智能时代，什么才算作弊？教师可以使用什么样的作业、项目和考试来确保他们的
students are really learning, not just copying AI-generated answers? What are the potential benefits of AI and education and how should colleges and universities think about educating an AI literate workforce in the future. Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills. I have two guests today. First is Dr. Eddie Watson, Vice President for Digital Innovation at the American Association of Colleges and Universities and founding director of the Association Institute on AI, pedagogy, and the curriculum. His work aims to help colleges move beyond fear or hype
学生确实是在学习，而不是仅仅复制人工智能生成的答案？人工智能在教育中的潜在好处是什么？学院和大学应该如何思考在未来培养具备人工智能素养的劳动力？欢迎收听《心理学谈话》（Speaking of Psychology），这是美国心理学会的旗舰播客，旨在探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是金·米尔斯（Kim Mills）。今天我有两位嘉宾。第一位是美国学院与大学协会（AAC&U）数字创新副总裁、人工智能、教学法与课程协会研究所创始主任埃迪·沃森（Eddie Watson）博士。他的工作旨在帮助高校超越恐惧或炒作，
toward a thoughtful, evidence-informed integration of AI into teaching and learning. He has focused on how institutions can respond to AI's challenges for academic integrity, student learning, curriculum design, and workforce preparation. He's the author of the book, Teaching with AI, a practical guide to a new era of human learning and was recently recognized by Ed Tech Magazine,
转向将人工智能深思熟虑且基于证据地整合到教学和学习中。他专注于机构如何应对人工智能在学术诚信、学生学习、课程设计和劳动力准备方面带来的挑战。他是《用人工智能教学：人类学习新时代的实用指南》（Teaching with AI, a practical guide to a new era of human learning）一书的作者，最近被《教育技术杂志》（Ed Tech Magazine）评为，
seen as one of the top 25 higher education influencers to follow in 26. My second guest is Dr. Beth Schwartz, Senior Director of Teaching and Learning at APA. She leads the association's efforts to advance evidence-based teaching and learning across educational settings. Before joining APA, Dr. Schwartz spent decades working in higher education as a psychology professor, university dean, and provost. She's a fellow of APA's Division to the Society for the Teaching of Psychology, and she's leading APA's efforts to provide educators with practical evidence-informed strategies on how to use AI in their classrooms guided by psychological research on how students learn. Dr. Schwartz, Dr. Watson, thank you for joining me today.
2026年最值得关注的25位高等教育影响者之一。我的第二位嘉宾是美国心理学会（APA）教学与学习高级主任贝丝·施瓦茨（Beth Schwartz）博士。她领导该协会在各种教育环境中推进基于证据的教学和学习。在加入APA之前，施瓦茨博士在高等教育领域工作了数十年，担任过心理学教授、大学院长和教务长。她是APA心理学教学分会的会员，目前正领导APA的工作，旨在根据关于学生如何学习的心理学研究，为教育工作者提供关于如何在课堂上使用人工智能的实用且基于证据的策略。施瓦茨博士、沃森博士，感谢你们今天参加我的节目。
Thanks for happiness. Yes, great to be here. Let's start by talking about how common AI use in the classroom is right now at the K-12 and university level. I mean, What do we know from research and surveys and what are you hearing from the educators you work with? Dr. Watson, maybe you want to grab that? Well, it's interesting that the data is a little bit mixed. We can probably estimate that it is a large percentage of students that are using it, especially at the university level. But surveys of students, you know, where they self-report how active they've been using Genitive AI, the results, depending on the survey, are wildly divergent.
谢谢邀请。是的，很高兴来到这里。让我们先谈谈目前在K-12（中小学）和大学阶段，人工智能在课堂上的使用有多普遍。我的意思是，我们从研究和调查中了解到了什么？你们从合作的教育工作者那里听到了什么？沃森博士，也许你想先谈谈？嗯，有趣的是，数据有些参差不齐。我们或许可以估计，很大比例的学生正在使用它，尤其是在大学阶段。但是，关于学生自我报告使用生成式人工智能活跃程度的调查，结果根据调查的不同而大相径庭。
I've seen them as low as in the 20% range and other surveys up near 90%. So I'm imagining that some students might not want to self-report that they have been using it. But without a doubt, I would imagine it's certainly more than half, maybe three-quarters of students are using it. And of course, there's a lot of different ways to use it. I mean, some students are using it for, you know, career planning or, to help them learn various topics. And of course, there are other ways that they might use it that might diminish their learning or might be outright cheating.
我见过低至20%左右的调查，也有高达90%左右的。所以我猜想，有些学生可能不想自我报告他们一直在使用它。但毫无疑问，我想肯定超过一半，也许四分之三的学生正在使用它。当然，使用它的方式有很多种。我的意思是，有些学生用它来进行职业规划，或者帮助他们学习各种主题。当然，还有其他一些使用方式可能会削弱他们的学习，或者可能直接就是作弊。
But certainly, the vast majority of students are indeed using AI today. And are we talking about mostly high school and college level or are kids younger than that using AI right now? In the primary schools and secondary schools, a lot of the surveys have focused less so on the student's use of AI and more so on the teacher's use of AI. And when we look at that, yeah, we see that it's obviously increased. a great deal in the last year and a half. The use by faculty or educators is about the same in the primary and secondary in higher ed where it's primary, it's about 43 percent and middle school.
但可以肯定的是，绝大多数学生今天确实在使用人工智能。我们谈论的主要是高中和大学水平，还是说比这更小的孩子现在也在使用人工智能？在小学和中学，许多调查较少关注学生对人工智能的使用，而更多关注教师对人工智能的使用。当我们观察这一点时，是的，我们看到它在过去一年半里显然有了很大的增长。教职员工或教育工作者在小学、中学和高等教育中的使用率大致相同，小学约为43%，初中约为
We see it about 63 percent, up to 72 percent in high school and college. So, but the use for students is, is much less common to be asked on those surveys. So we have much less data on that. There is more in the high school use, but in the primary and secondary, schools, educators are still trying to figure out for themselves how to use it, let alone how to incorporate it into the learning environment for those younger students. Yeah, and we'll talk about that, but Dr. Schwartz, I want to ask you, what are the biggest concerns you hear from educators about how the students are using AI? And we see time and time again, I think the top two concerns reflect cognitive offloading,
63%，高中和大学则高达72%。所以，学生的使用情况在这些调查中被问及的频率要低得多。因此，我们掌握的相关数据要少得多。高中阶段的使用情况更多一些，但在小学和中学，教育工作者们仍在试图弄清楚自己该如何使用它，更不用说如何将其融入到那些低龄学生的学习环境中去了。是的，我们稍后会谈到这一点，但施瓦茨博士，我想问您，您从教育工作者那里听到的关于学生如何使用人工智能的最大担忧是什么？我们一次又一次地看到，我认为前两大担忧反映了认知卸载，
which simply means that the AI is doing the thinking, the reasoning for them, and in other words, they're not learning. And there's the issue of cheating or academic integrity. Those kind of rise to the top when you ask educators about AI, but there's also concerns about the fact that the reliability of AI, so they're speaking less so about the learning part, but just what the content is when they're using it or their students are using it. Educators also speak sometimes about the erosion of trust that happens because whether or not students turn in work, then they have to determine whether or not it's the student's work or the work of AI and that relationship that exists between the student and the faculty member can be eroded just by those questions.
这简单来说就是人工智能在替他们思考和推理，换句话说，他们没有在学习。还有作弊或学术诚信的问题。当你问教育工作者关于人工智能的问题时，这些问题往往排在首位。但人们也担心人工智能的可靠性，所以他们谈论的不是学习部分，而是当他们或他们的学生使用它时，内容本身是什么。教育工作者有时也会谈到信任的侵蚀，因为无论学生是否提交了作业，他们都必须确定这到底是学生自己的作品还是人工智能的作品，而学生与教职员工之间存在的这种关系可能会仅仅因为这些问题而受到侵蚀。
There's issues of equity that's of concern, so does everybody have the access that they need when AI is available, particularly since there are some that are free and some that are where there's costs? And I've heard often from faculty about just the lack of professional development. So there's an expectation sometimes for administrators that they should be using AI. And yet they are not given professional development on the technical professionacy that they need or the pedagogical strategies that they need to learn to incorporate AI into their everyday classrooms. Well, Dr. Watson, that's something that you're working on, right?
还有公平性问题，即当人工智能可用时，每个人是否都有所需的访问权限，特别是考虑到有些是免费的，而有些是有成本的？我经常从教职员工那里听到关于缺乏专业发展的抱怨。行政人员有时会期望他们应该使用人工智能。然而，他们并没有获得所需的关于技术熟练度或教学策略的专业发展，以学习如何将人工智能融入到他们的日常课堂中。嗯，沃森博士，这正是您正在努力解决的问题，对吧？
Can you talk about that? So specifically how faculty are using AI in the classroom? Yeah. Well, I guess what we're kind of. of seeing that there's maybe 20% of faculty, give or take, that are sort of leaning into figuring out how to use AI themselves, you know, leveraging it from the improvement of learning outcomes for their students. There's probably this big middle of 70% that are sort of like wait and see, but sort of like learning to use it in a variety of different small ways. And then there's
您能谈谈吗？具体来说，教职员工是如何在课堂上使用人工智能的？是的。嗯，我想我们看到的情况是，大约有20%左右的教职员工正在倾向于弄清楚如何自己使用人工智能，你知道，利用它来改善学生的学习成果。可能有一个占70%的大中间群体，他们处于观望状态，但也在以各种不同的小方式学习使用它。然后还有
certainly a resistance pocket as well. So it's kind of like the broader land. of how faculty, at least are self-reporting that they're using AI. But then when it comes to specifically the notion of leveraging AI for maybe teaching and learning purposes or course improvement, there are literally tools out there that help with every aspect of sort of the teaching and learning lifecycle from developing a syllabus to finding course materials to sorting course materials to assignment design, putting together lectures, developing PowerPoint slide decks, creating active learning activities for the classroom, all the way through providing feedback to students and even grading about a year ago
当然也存在一个抵制群体。所以这大致就是教职员工至少在自我报告中如何使用人工智能的概况。但当谈到专门利用人工智能进行教学和学习或课程改进时，确实有工具可以帮助教学和学习生命周期的各个方面，从制定教学大纲到寻找课程材料、整理课程材料、作业设计、组织讲座、制作PPT幻灯片、为课堂创建主动学习活动，一直到为学生提供反馈甚至评分。大约一年前
or a little bit less than a year ago. One of the big learning management system providers came out with tools nested within university learning management systems that purports to be able to grade just about anything. So the question is, it's like, Like, yes, AI can do these things, but do we want AI to do these things? Is this something that we would like to ask AI to perform that kind of task? Or are there certain aspects that really belong within the identity of what it is to be a professor in higher education? A lot of that's being hotly debated right now. Yeah, because from what you described, I mean, basically AI, it sounds like can do almost anything, right? I mean, why do you need a teacher if AI can do all of these? these things. Well, isn't that that's one of the debated topics. In fact, I had an interview with a press outlet just yesterday about a new program that had
或者不到一年前，大型学习管理系统提供商之一推出了嵌套在大学学习管理系统中的工具，声称能够对几乎任何东西进行评分。所以问题在于，是的，人工智能可以做这些事情，但我们希望人工智能做这些事情吗？这是我们想要要求人工智能执行的那种任务吗？还是说有些方面确实属于高等教育教授身份的一部分？很多问题现在正被激烈争论。是的，因为根据您的描述，我的意思是，基本上人工智能听起来几乎可以做任何事情，对吧？我的意思是，如果人工智能可以做所有这些事情，为什么还需要老师呢？嗯，这不是争论的话题之一吗？事实上，我昨天刚接受了一家媒体的采访，谈到了一个新项目，该项目
been launched in London. It's a master's program that's largely taught by AI. So is that a good idea? That was the question for me was like, do you think this is a good idea? And it's like, well, I guess I'm of different minds. I mean, one is very much from a learning aspect. Like, would there be evidence to show that how they've designed and are leveraging AI, does it result in learning outcomes that are at similar or the same level of proficiency as a face-to-face program? And indeed, these are questions that we ask about online learning 25, 30 years ago, right?
已经在伦敦启动。这是一个主要由人工智能教授的硕士课程。那么这是一个好主意吗？这就是问我的问题，你认为这是一个好主意吗？我的想法是，我对此有不同的看法。一方面，从学习的角度来看，是否有证据表明他们设计和利用人工智能的方式，是否能产生与面对面课程水平相当或相同的学习成果？事实上，这些正是我们25、30年前问在线学习的问题，对吧？
So it's kind of like the same kinds of questions. And then we, of course, through inquiry around face-to-face and online learning, we found that there's nuances, right? I mean, online learning can be done very successfully, but it's like when done well, it can have really good outcomes. And when done poorly, face-to-face instruction could be worse than an online course. So I think that that's likely going to be the outcomes of some of these, I guess, emerging studies around leveraging AI for instructional purposes. But we don't know yet, right?
所以这有点像同样的问题。当然，通过围绕面对面学习和在线学习的探究，我们发现其中存在细微差别，对吧？我的意思是，在线学习可以做得非常成功，但当做得好时，它可以有非常好的结果。而当做得不好时，面对面教学可能比在线课程更糟糕。所以我认为，这很可能是围绕利用人工智能进行教学目的的一些新兴研究的结果。但我们还不知道，对吧？
I mean, those research studies haven't been done. And certainly evidence should guide, you know, the practice that we might have. employ or where we might encourage our students, you know. Well, Dr. Schwartz, let me ask you this. This is not the first time that people have worried about disruptive technology and education. I mean, AI is just the latest example of schools and universities and students needing to adapt to changing technology, whether it was calculators or Google, you know,
我的意思是，那些研究还没有完成。当然，证据应该指导我们可能采用的实践，或者我们可能鼓励学生去做的方向。嗯，施瓦茨博士，让我问您这个问题。这并不是人们第一次担心颠覆性技术对教育的影响。我的意思是，人工智能只是学校、大学和学生需要适应不断变化的技术的最新例子，无论是计算器还是谷歌，你知道，
is now we've got AI as that fundamentally different from these earlier disruptions, do you think? Right. That's a great question. And one that I'm often asked on the. calculator examples often brought up and then the internet. And most educators would agree that it's fundamentally different. And it's fundamentally different because, well, the calculator, right, it did routine computations, right? It didn't do any arithmetic thinking.
现在我们有了人工智能，您认为它与这些早期的颠覆性技术有本质上的不同吗？对。这是一个很好的问题。我经常被问到这个问题。计算器的例子经常被提起，然后是互联网。大多数教育工作者会同意它有本质上的不同。它有本质上的不同是因为，嗯，计算器，对吧，它做的是常规计算，对吧？它没有进行任何算术思考。
It didn't come to arithmetic conclusions like concepts or reasoning. The search function, like of the Google search, it just removed the search process from the learning. And I remember as a faculty member, I would sit there and think about the times I had to go to the library, open up those onion-skinned abstract books to find the articles for psych info. And then I was teaching and my students could literally just lie they are with their laptop and just find something instantly. And I thought to myself, but that's not a learning goal of mine, right?
它没有得出像概念或推理这样的算术结论。搜索功能，比如谷歌搜索，它只是把搜索过程从学习中移除了。我记得作为一名教职员工，我会坐在那里思考我不得不去图书馆，打开那些洋葱皮纸的摘要书来查找心理学信息（Psych Info）文章的时光。然后我正在教学，我的学生可以坐在那里，用他们的笔记本电脑瞬间找到东西。我心想，但这并不是我的学习目标，对吧？
That's not one of my learning goals. So it's okay for the search process that's being assisted with the Internet and with Google search is to get in the way of learning. Whereas AI is a much different type of technology. Right now, it's producing the output. It's producing the evidence of learning that students are turning in. So it's a very different type of disruption. It generates explanations. It writes essays, right? It does problem solving instantly for students. So between solving problems, summarizing readings, and the list can go on, it's a very different type of output. Who can be? to the former technologies that were considered disruptive in the classroom.
那不是我的学习目标之一。所以，通过互联网和谷歌搜索辅助的搜索过程妨碍学习是可以接受的。而人工智能是一种完全不同类型的技术。现在，它正在产生输出。它正在产生学生提交的学习证据。所以这是一种非常不同类型的颠覆。它生成解释，它撰写论文，对吧？它瞬间为学生解决问题。因此，在解决问题、总结阅读材料之间，列表还可以继续，这与之前被认为在课堂上具有颠覆性的技术相比，是一种非常不同类型的输出。谁能成为？
Well, so Dr. Watson, keying off of that, do you think AI is going to erode students' critical thinking ability? Well, we did a survey at AAC and you. It was sealed it in November of 2025, published in January of 2026. It's available full text online. It's called the AI Challenge. And we surveyed faculty in higher education across all disciplines, all institutions, all institutions, types. And of that corpus of intelligence, 90% of respondents said that they thought that generative AI will diminish students' critical thinking skills, that that was their perception. And more than two-thirds said that it was going to have a significant impact, like a really large impact on students' critical thinking skills. So that's a lot of opinion that points in the
嗯，那么沃森博士，顺着这一点，您认为人工智能会侵蚀学生的批判性思维能力吗？嗯，我们在AAC&U做了一项调查。它在2025年11月完成，2026年1月发布。它可以在线获取全文。它被称为“人工智能挑战”（The AI Challenge）。我们调查了所有学科、所有机构类型的高等教育教职员工。在这些情报语料库中，90%的受访者表示，他们认为生成式人工智能会削弱学生的批判性思维能力，这是他们的看法。超过三分之二的人表示，它将产生重大影响，即对学生的批判性思维能力产生非常大的影响。所以，很多观点都指向
same direction that is likely suggestive of an outcome that we will around student usage of generative AI, if we're not careful, you know, there's definitely functional intervention that we could do to address that. But without that, we could expect that erosion. Well, and what are those interventions? What do you do to ensure that your students are still, you know, using their full brain power? Well, it's interesting. I mean, it varies from one discipline to the next.
同一个方向，这很可能暗示了如果我们不小心，围绕学生使用生成式人工智能会出现的结果。你知道，我们肯定可以进行功能性干预来解决这个问题。但如果没有这些，我们可能会预见到那种侵蚀。嗯，那么这些干预措施是什么？您怎么做才能确保您的学生仍然在使用他们全部的脑力？嗯，这很有趣。我的意思是，它因学科而异。
But I think, you know, part of it is engendering in students a healthy dose of skepticism regarding the output of generative AI, that AI doesn't do the work for you, but it does work with you, but you're the executive decision maker. You see the output, you have to evaluate it. You should read every sentence. You should examine every line of code and you should anticipate that there will be things that you would need to correct. Or if it's not wrong, that you, as the human partner in this, as the one providing oversight, that you could improve the quality of the output given the nuance of understanding you have regarding whatever the particular task might be. So I think what we need to teach students going forward is a new habit of mind that is to have
但我认为，你知道，部分原因是在学生中培养对生成式人工智能输出的健康怀疑态度，即人工智能不会为你做工作，但它确实与你一起工作，而你是执行决策者。你看到输出，你必须评估它。你应该阅读每一个句子。你应该检查每一行代码，并且你应该预料到会有你需要纠正的地方。或者如果它没有错，作为人类合作伙伴，作为提供监督的人，你可以根据你对特定任务的细微理解来提高输出的质量。所以我认为我们需要教给学生的是一种新的思维习惯，那就是拥有
this, this ongoing, almost moment to moment level of critique or criticism of the output of AI expecting that it will not have accurate outputs and then to engage with it appropriately. So that's new habit of mind that I think is part of a signature pedagogy for high education. And I'll just add that that requires faculty to to reconsider or redesign their assignments so that that can incorporate what Eddie just described into those assignments because a lot of the assignments that faculty for decades have used have not required that reflection because they didn't have that tool that would generate the answers for them. But now with that tool in mind, we have to sit back and think about the exact assignment and can it be done with AI?
这种持续的、几乎是时刻的对人工智能输出的批判或批评，预期它不会有准确的输出，然后适当地与它互动。所以我认为这是高等教育标志性教学法的一部分。我还要补充一点，这需要教职员工重新考虑或重新设计他们的作业，以便能够将埃迪刚才描述的内容纳入这些作业中，因为教职员工几十年来使用的许多作业并没有要求这种反思，因为他们没有那种可以为他们生成答案的工具。但现在有了那个工具，我们必须坐下来思考具体的作业，它可以用人工智能完成吗？
Can it be done without AI? And when is AI removing the effort for learning, right? That we know that and leads to understanding, retaining information and when is AI actually enhancing the learning? So redesigning assignments with those thoughts in mind will help students also in the end with greater learning outcomes. We're going to take a short break. When we return, we'll talk more about cheating and what constitutes fair use of AI for both students and educators. I want to talk about cheating. A lot of the public conversation around AI and education has focused on this.
它可以在没有人工智能的情况下完成吗？什么时候人工智能是在消除学习所需的努力，对吧？我们知道这会导致理解、保留信息，而什么时候人工智能实际上是在增强学习？因此，带着这些想法重新设计作业最终也会帮助学生获得更好的学习成果。我们要休息一下。回来后，我们将更多地讨论作弊以及对学生和教育工作者来说，什么是人工智能的合理使用。我想谈谈作弊。围绕人工智能和教育的许多公众对话都集中在这一点上。
How should educators and students think about what constitutes cheating with AI versus what is legitimate permitted assistance? And cheating is a question and a concern that, as I said earlier, is a top concern for faculty. And I always always want to mention when people ask questions about generative AI and cheating is that it's not what created cheating, right? We know that cheating has been around for and has been a problem, academic dishonesty has been there long before generative AI came about because we had to do it with cutting and pasting from those searches that students were doing. And then we had the larger issue of paper mills
教育工作者和学生应该如何思考什么是人工智能作弊，什么是合法的允许辅助？作弊是一个问题和担忧，正如我之前所说，是教职员工的首要担忧。当人们问关于生成式人工智能和作弊的问题时，我总是想提到，它并不是创造作弊的东西，对吧？我们知道作弊一直存在，并且一直是一个问题，学术不诚实在生成式人工智能出现之前就已经存在了，因为我们必须通过剪切和粘贴学生们正在做的那些搜索来完成它。然后我们还有论文工厂的更大问题，
where students could purchase papers. And I don't know if you've ever gone to those sites, but in the past when I was researching cheating and you can put in the topic, the grade level, the grade that you want, the date that you wanted it. So they were very sophisticated ways of cheating prior to generative AI. When it comes to defining cheating,
学生可以在那里购买论文。我不知道你是否去过那些网站，但在过去我研究作弊时，你可以输入主题、年级、你想要的成绩、你想要的日期。所以在生成式人工智能之前，就有非常复杂的作弊方式。当谈到定义作弊时，
what research shows us is that students and faculty define cheating very differently. When you give them examples of academic behavior, you don't get agreement in what they consider to be cheating. And a lot of that has to do with the fact that you have, faculty or educators have to define very clearly for their students what their expectations are and have clear policies on when they can use AI and when they should not use AI. And what we find is that the best practice that reduces cheating overall is when you talk about academic integrity with students. When you have that conversation and you talk openly and clearly and regularly and not just one time because we typically, most faculty have it on their syllabus and they
研究向我们表明，学生和教职员工对作弊的定义非常不同。当你给他们学术行为的例子时，他们对什么被认为是作弊并没有达成一致。这很大程度上是因为教职员工必须非常清楚地为他们的学生定义他们的期望，并制定明确的政策，规定何时可以使用人工智能，何时不应该使用人工智能。我们发现，减少整体作弊的最佳实践是与学生讨论学术诚信。当你进行那种对话，并且公开、清晰、定期地讨论，而不仅仅是一次，因为我们通常，大多数教职员工在教学大纲上有它，并且他们
have a statement about academic integrity and define cheating there. But just stating it one time at the beginning of the semester is not enough. We find that if you repeat it over and over again with each assignment and explain to students what is allowable, then you reduce the likelihood of academic dishonesty. And the same is true for generative AI. You have to be clear how they can use AI in the assignment that you're giving to them. And if you don't, the assumptions will be made. And this is actually a big concern for students. We hear from students that they don't know when to use it, and it creates great anxiety. And that's the last thing that we want to do. So that communication piece is really important. So Dr. Watson, is there any work toward developing a
在那里有一份关于学术诚信的声明并定义了作弊。但仅仅在学期开始时陈述一次是不够的。我们发现，如果你在每次作业中反复强调它，并向学生解释什么是允许的，那么你就会降低学术不诚实的可能性。对于生成式人工智能也是如此。你必须明确他们如何在给他们的作业中使用人工智能。如果你不这样做，就会产生假设。这实际上是学生们非常关心的问题。我们从学生那里听到，他们不知道什么时候使用它，这会产生巨大的焦虑。而这正是我们最不想做的事情。所以沟通部分非常重要。那么沃森博士，是否有任何工作致力于开发一个
consensus around the standards so that if I'm a student, for example, I know, okay, I can't use AI to write my paper, but can I use AI to write the outline, for example? Well, that's a really good example, we actually gave, in that survey that I mentioned to faculty, we found that there were large disagreements about what constitutes legitimate and illegitimate uses of generative AI. We gave scenarios and writing, you know, working from an outline was one of them. In fact, we gave, the language was, a student receives a writing assignment and asks AI to provide a detailed outline of an appropriate response. The student then follows the outline to write the paper. 52% said that that was an example of how to use AI to cheat, while the other 48% said,
关于标准的共识，以便例如如果我是一名学生，我知道，好的，我不能用人工智能写我的论文，但我可以用人工智能写大纲吗？嗯，这是一个非常好的例子，我们实际上在给教职员工的那项调查中，发现对于什么是生成式人工智能的合法和非法使用存在巨大的分歧。我们给出了场景和写作，你知道，从大纲开始工作就是其中之一。事实上，我们给出的语言是，一名学生收到写作作业，并要求人工智能提供适当回应的详细大纲。学生然后按照大纲写论文。52%的人说这是如何使用人工智能作弊的例子，而另外48%的人说，
Mrs. Faculty again, said that it was either legitimate or they weren't quite sure. And to be honest, I think it depends on what the learning goal might be. Like if you wanted students to have practice writing, and sometimes it's difficult, you know, when you're 17, 18 years old to think of something to write about. And so having an outline and then now you have something that you can practice, you know, creating sentences and grammar and syntax and all of those things. For that goal, that learning goal, that's very helpful. But then on the other side of things, maybe you're not using writing to learn to write,
这又是教职员工，说它要么是合法的，要么他们不太确定。老实说，我认为这取决于学习目标可能是什么。比如如果你想让学生练习写作，有时这很困难，你知道，当你17、18岁时，很难想到要写什么。所以有一个大纲，然后现在你就有了一些可以练习的东西，你知道，创造句子、语法、句法以及所有这些东西。对于那个目标，那个学习目标，这非常有帮助。但另一方面，也许你不是在用写作来学习写作，
but you're using writing to learn other things. And then in that case, you want to see the students thinking as made transparent by their writing. So I think that's why there's such disagreement is like the scenario doesn't speak to what the learning goal is. I think the learning goal is going to vary from one assignment to the next, from one faculty member to the next, and as a result, I don't think we're going to find a consensus regarding what is the best way to use generative AI or what is a legitimate versus illegitimate way to use AI. In fact, I think that, you know, most institutions now have some level of policy, and often the policy says, look at the faculty members' syllabus. But I even go
而是在用写作来学习其他东西。那么在这种情况下，你希望看到学生的思考通过他们的写作变得透明。所以我认为这就是为什么会有如此大的分歧，场景并没有说明学习目标是什么。我认为学习目标会因作业而异，因教职员工而异，因此，我不认为我们会就什么是使用生成式人工智能的最佳方式或什么是合法与非法使用人工智能的方式达成共识。事实上，我认为，你知道，大多数机构现在都有某种程度的政策，而且政策通常说，看看教职员工的教学大纲。但我甚至走得
further in recommending that we're probably at a moment where we don't just mention on the syllabus, but probably every assignment we give students, even a discussion board post should address that question. Like, can't use AI for this particular assignment and also address the question of why or why not? I think far more likely to follow along if we make our pedagogical choices transparent. Oh, I can see, you know, I don't have enough foundational knowledge to be able to use AI in this way.
更远，建议我们可能正处于一个时刻，我们不仅在教学大纲上提到，而且可能我们给学生的每一份作业，甚至讨论板帖子都应该解决这个问题。比如，不能在这个特定作业中使用人工智能，还要解决为什么或为什么不的问题？我认为如果我们使我们的教学选择透明，他们更有可能跟随。哦，我可以看到，你知道，我没有足够的知识基础来能够以这种方式使用人工智能。
yet as a partner, I would just be leaning on it too much. And so it's more of a conversation than we've ever had regarding our teaching choices and our teaching practice to make sure that we're providing students with guidance and understanding so that they'll be more willing to follow along with the recommendations that we make. And I'll just add, because Eddie brought up a great point, is the question of whether or not there should be an institutional policy versus just leaving it up to the faculty and giving the autonomy to the faculty. And when, if you put yourself in the role of the student, if they have to go from one class to the next and figure out what that each educator's policy is, that gets very confusing.
作为合作伙伴，我只是会太依赖它了。所以这比我们以往任何时候关于我们的教学选择和教学实践的对话都要多，以确保我们为学生提供指导和理解，这样他们会更愿意遵循我们提出的建议。我还要补充一点，因为埃迪提出了一个很好的观点，是关于是否应该有机构政策，而不是仅仅留给教职员工并给予他们自主权的问题。当你，如果你把自己置于学生的角色，如果他们必须从一门课到另一门课，并弄清楚每位教育工作者的政策是什么，那会变得非常令人困惑。
If there can be one overarching one, that could be helpful. But as Eddie pointed out, it's the learning goal of each and every assignment that will determine when it's appropriate and how is it appropriate to use AI for that particular piece of work. That's what's going to learn to, that's what will lead to achieving the learning goals and having students, you know, learn to whatever skill it is or content it is that you want them to achieve. Yeah, I think that that's really good points. I think students though have been, even whenever all of us were back in college, we navigated the syllabus, right? We'd go to one class that's like class participation's worth 40% of the grade here and here it's worth 5%. So then I might adjust my behaviors. I know I kind of
如果能有一个总体政策，那可能会有帮助。但正如埃迪指出的那样，每一份作业的学习目标将决定何时合适以及如何合适地为那件特定的工作使用人工智能。这就是将学习到，这就是将导致实现学习目标并让学生，你知道，学习到你希望他们实现的任何技能或内容。是的，我认为这些是非常好的观点。但我认为学生们，即使在我们所有人都回到大学时，我们也浏览过教学大纲，对吧？我们会去一门课，说课堂参与度在这里占成绩的40%，而在这里占5%。所以我可能会调整我的行为。我知道我有点
have to be social today because I'm in that particular psychology class versus my math class or whatever it might be. It adds additional levels of sophistication to that navigating from one class to the next. But given that learning should dictate a lot of the choices regarding technology use and and indeed, as grade breakdown is distributed within a class, it's complexity, and it does make it more difficult for the students, but that just further signals that this is additional change, not so much in student practice, but in faculty practice. What about for faculty, what would constitute, quote, cheating or an unethical use of AI? For example, could you use AI to read all your students' papers and assign grades?
必须在今天社交，因为我在那门特定的心理学课上，而不是我的数学课或其他什么。它为从一门课到另一门课的导航增加了额外的复杂性。但鉴于学习应该决定关于技术使用的大部分选择，以及确实，成绩分配在课堂内是如何分布的，它是复杂的，它确实让学生更困难，但这进一步表明这是额外的变化，不是学生实践的变化，而是教职员工实践的变化。那么对于教职员工，什么构成“作弊”或人工智能的不道德使用？例如，您可以使用人工智能阅读所有学生的论文并打分吗？
Can you use it to develop the syllabus? And where is the line for the faculty member? Well, so we included questions in that survey, specifically about the profession of the faculty member. Like, is it okay to use it to, you know, create your syllabus? Or is it okay to leverage it in some minor ways in terms of scholarship? And when we're talking about, you know, creating an article to submit to a journal,
您可以使用它来制定教学大纲吗？教职员工的界限在哪里？嗯，所以我们在那项调查中包含了问题，专门关于教职员工的职业。比如，使用它来，你知道，创建你的教学大纲可以吗？或者在学术方面以某种微小的方式利用它可以吗？当我们谈论，你知道，创建一篇文章提交给期刊时，
more than four out of five, a faculty said, know that is an illegitimate use, an unprofessional use of AI. And as you got sort of further down the food chain of teaching from syllabus to development all the way to grading, there is less and less comfort with using AI for those purposes. You know, so specifically like we ask a faculty member uses generative AI tools to grade essays in their course. 71% said that that was an illegitimate use for faculty to leverage AI in that way. 10% only 10% said outright, yes, that is acceptable. Another 20%, 19%, they said that they weren't really sure.
超过五分之四的教职员工说，知道那是一种非法使用，一种不专业的人工智能使用。当你从教学大纲到开发一直到评分，沿着教学的食物链往下走，对将人工智能用于这些目的的舒适度越来越低。你知道，所以具体来说，比如我们问一名教职员工使用生成式人工智能工具来给他们课程中的论文评分。71%的人说那是教职员工以那种方式利用人工智能的非法使用。10%只有10%的人直接说，是的，那是可以接受的。另外20%，19%，他们说他们不太确定。
But it's suggestive that we need to have larger conversations because there are some that indeed see it as acceptable and are indeed doing it. And then there are others that see it as, you know, really just absurd for a professor to think about allowing AI to do the grading in a course. So there's, again, this everything is evolving, right? And we still haven't gotten to a sense of like what are the common norms, even for our own practice within our own disciplines regarding using generative AI. Right. And it brings up acceptance and transparency as well. If you think your colleagues believe that use of generative AI is not acceptable, you're, even when you do use it, you're not going to be transparent that you're using it. And that brings up a whole other issue in the world of education. So that, Eddie Sir Wright, in terms of that conversation is needed to really better understand when is it acceptable, when is it appropriate. Because I've also heard students of concern about their faculty members using generative AI to grade their work.
但这表明我们需要进行更广泛的对话，因为确实有些人认为它是可以接受的，并且确实正在这样做。然后还有其他人认为，你知道，教授考虑允许人工智能在课程中评分简直是荒谬的。所以，再次，这一切都在演变，对吧？我们仍然没有达成一种共识，即什么是共同规范，即使对于我们在各自学科内关于使用生成式人工智能的实践。对。它也带来了接受度和透明度的问题。如果你认为你的同事认为使用生成式人工智能是不可接受的，你，即使当你使用它时，你也不会透明地表示你正在使用它。这在教育界引发了另一个问题。所以，埃迪说得对，就那种对话而言，需要真正更好地理解何时它是可以接受的，何时它是合适的。因为我也听到学生们担心他们的教职员工使用生成式人工智能来给他们的工作评分。
I mean, you're not reading my papers. You're using this technology to give me a grade, which for them is disconcerting. Sure, sure. Yeah, I think that's really, I think important for faculty to be transparent with their students if they do indeed make that choice. And if they do make that choice for grading specifically, again, the explanation of here's why I'm doing this, because you're going to get feedback immediately. Here's a process where if you want to debate the grade that you receive, you would prefer to have a human grade it. Here's a path for that. But you know, whatever the rules are, be transparent with students and talk about what the benefits are to them.
我的意思是，你没有读我的论文。你正在使用这种技术给我打分，这对他们来说是令人不安的。当然，当然。是的，我认为这真的，我认为对于教职员工来说，如果他们确实做出了那个选择，对学生透明是非常重要的。如果他们确实为评分做出了那个选择，同样，解释我为什么要这样做，因为你将立即获得反馈。这是一个过程，如果你想辩论你收到的成绩，你会更喜欢让人类来评分。这里有一条路径。但你知道，无论规则是什么，对学生透明，并谈论对他们有什么好处。
But there's, you know, also the other side of the clinic, what do students really think? And as we were putting together the second edition of teaching with AI, we did a number of different student focus groups. And we asked students the question. And I had made the erroneous assumption that students would not want this, that they would not want faculty to be using AI for grading. And it was diversity of perspectives that emerged. One student said, you know, I think I was. would prefer that because I think AI would be more fair. And he said, you know, I kind of have a, I lean more politically to the right. And I'm kind of careful about things that I say in class as a result. But, you know, I think if I voice some opinions, I'm afraid that the, that the faculty member might get back at me through grading. You know, I had another student say that they showed up
但还有，你知道，硬币的另一面，学生们到底怎么想？当我们整理《用人工智能教学》第二版时，我们做了许多不同的学生焦点小组。我们问了学生这个问题。我做出了错误的假设，认为学生不会想要这个，他们不会想要教职员工使用人工智能进行评分。结果出现了多样化的观点。一名学生说，你知道，我想我会更喜欢那样，因为我认为人工智能会更公平。他说，你知道，我在政治上更倾向于右翼。所以我对我在课堂上说的话很小心。但是，你知道，我想如果我表达一些观点，我担心教职员工可能会通过评分来报复我。你知道，我有另一名学生说他们第一天
late for the first day of class and they thought that their professor had it out for them for the entire semester because of that first day of class. So they like the idea of AI grading as a unbiased arbiter of the graded work. Which is interesting because we know the bias that exists in AI itself, right? Sure. For like people who have English as a second language or even gender differences that there's some clear biases. So yeah, that's an interesting point, Eddie. But AI won't know that you were late. Well, how might AI change the sorts of tests and assessments that teachers use to evaluate their students? I mean, I've read that there's been an increase in orders for those old-fashioned blue books that a lot of us used in college.
上课迟到了，他们认为他们的教授整个学期都针对他们，因为第一天的那节课。所以他们喜欢人工智能评分的想法，作为评分工作的公正仲裁者。这很有趣，因为我们知道人工智能本身存在的偏见，对吧？当然。对于像英语作为第二语言的人，甚至性别差异，都有一些明显的偏见。所以是的，这是一个有趣的观点，埃迪。但人工智能不会知道你迟到了。嗯，人工智能可能会如何改变教师用来评估学生的测试和评估类型？我的意思是，我读到那些我们许多人在大学里使用的老式蓝皮书的订单有所增加。
Will teachers need to go back to handwritten or oral tests and assignments? There definitely has been an increase in blue books, and that's the one thing I hear from faculty most often is that they're asking. for some work that's taking place right in the classroom where it's proctered or supervised, and that's, or where no technology, so to speak, is available for students to use for answers. So essentially, many faculty are redesigning those assignments. In some cases, assignments where AI is not allowed to be used, or in other cases where AI is allowed, but there's clear guidelines to ensure that the learning goals are more. met. But he was really where basic learning science can guide the way because AI will hurt when
教师需要回到手写或口头测试和作业吗？蓝皮书确实有所增加，这是我从教职员工那里听到最频繁的一件事，就是他们要求进行一些在课堂上进行的、有监考或监督的工作，那是，或者说没有技术，可以说，可供学生用来获取答案。所以本质上，许多教职员工正在重新设计那些作业。在某些情况下，是不允许使用人工智能的作业，或者在其他情况下，允许使用人工智能，但有明确的指导方针以确保学习目标得到更多满足。但埃迪确实是基本学习科学可以指导方向的地方，因为人工智能会伤害，当
you remove the effort that's involved in learning. So when there's shortcuts for problem solving and it leads to what I guess you'll call it passive acceptance of answers, that's when AI acts like a substitute and it's doing the work for you. And faculty are trying to avoid take on tests, for example. I mean, I don't know what many faculty these days, even if you give clear guidance. When I worked at a college with an honor system and an honor code and all of my exams were just placed on at my door with two envelopes, one that said, here's the test and here's where you return the test, take it where you will throughout this 24 hours. I wonder how many faculty can still do that even at an institution with an honor system where AI is available.
你消除了学习中涉及的努力时。所以当解决问题有捷径，并且导致我猜你会称之为对答案的被动接受时，那就是人工智能充当替代品的时候，它在为你做工作。教师们正试图避免带回家的测试，例如。我的意思是，我不知道现在许多教职员工，即使你给出明确的指导。当我曾在一家拥有荣誉系统和荣誉准则的学院工作时，我所有的考试都只是放在我的门口，有两个信封，一个写着，这是测试，这是你归还测试的地方，在这24小时内随你带到哪里去。我想知道即使在拥有荣誉系统的机构中，当人工智能可用时，还有多少教职员工能做到这一点。
faculty are more likely to do more assessment of learning in the classroom. So it could be oral exams where the person is, the student is speaking. It could be in classroom work using blue books or not, as opposed to, I'm, I would guess, and Eddie, I don't know if I don't recall if the AAC and you survey asked this, but less homework assignments, right? Will there be fewer homework assignments where there's less monitoring of what's taking place when the students are completing the work, because the big question is when students turn in that product, can you tell whether or it's student work or AI generated work? That's the ultimate question there. I had a colleague this spring. She was telling me that, well, you know, I'm making this
教职员工更有可能在课堂上进行更多的学习评估。这可能是口试，也就是学生在说话。也可能是课堂作业，用不用蓝皮书都可以，而不是像我猜的那样——埃迪，我不记得美国大学与学院协会（AAC&U）的调查是否问过这个问题——减少家庭作业，对吧？家庭作业会减少吗？因为在学生完成作业时，对学习过程的监控会变少，而最大的问题是，当学生提交作业时，你能分辨出这是学生自己的作品还是人工智能生成的作品吗？这才是终极问题。今年春天我有一位同事，她告诉我，嗯，你知道，我正在做这个
interesting observation. My students are doing really good on the homework, but they're doing really poorly on the in-class exams. I don't know what that means. It's like, well, what do you think that means? If when you're watching them, they do poorly, but when they're home, do you think they might be getting assistance in any sort? So there's things that we can do in our class
有趣的观察。我的学生在家庭作业上表现得非常好，但在课堂考试中却表现得很差。我不知道这意味着什么。就像是，嗯，你觉得这意味着什么？如果在你监督他们时，他们表现得很差，但当他们在家里时，你认为他们是否可能得到了某种帮助？所以，我们可以在课堂上做一些事情
to collect, you know, information to better guide, you know, some of our practice or at least inform what's actually taking place within the classroom. But, you know, everything that Beth just shared are observations that we're seeing at AAC and you. And I also have the good fortune of having an end of two in my household. So I've got two sons that are college age. And this past summer, my youngest came home from college and I was doing the dad thing.
来收集信息，以更好地指导我们的一些实践，或者至少了解课堂内实际发生了什么。但是，你知道，贝丝刚才分享的一切都是我们在AAC&U观察到的现象。而且我也有幸家里有两个处于大学年龄的儿子。去年夏天，我的小儿子从大学回家，我尽到了做父亲的责任。
So son, how was college? You know, how did you do on the finals? And he said, well, you know, it was interesting. I did great on the finals. But for two of them, I had to go to the bookstore and buy a packet of paper stapled together. And I said, well, was the cover blue? Who? And he was like, Dan, how did you know? I keep up on the latest trends in higher education, son. That's my job.
我说，儿子，大学怎么样？你知道，期末考试考得怎么样？他说，嗯，你知道，很有趣。我期末考试考得很好。但其中两门课，我不得不去书店买一叠订在一起的纸。我说，封面是蓝色的吗？谁？他就像是，丹，你怎么知道的？我紧跟高等教育的最新趋势，儿子。这是我的工作。
Wow. I didn't have to pay for them. I was lucky, I guess. But speaking again about basically being able to suss out what's the students work and what's AI, I mean, do detectors work and should faculty rely on those tools to figure out whether their students are doing the work themselves or using AI? From the research that I read, the detectors, if I were in a classroom, I would not be using those detectors because the range of accuracy of the detectors is so great that if I was placing the percentage that was created by that detector on a high-stakes type of assignment, I just don't think it would provide fair grading. So I, and the interesting thing is that the people who are generating or developing the generative
哇。我不用付钱买它们。我想我很幸运。但再次谈到基本能够分辨什么是学生的作品，什么是人工智能，我的意思是，检测器有效吗？教职员工是否应该依赖这些工具来判断学生是在自己完成作业还是在使用人工智能？根据我读到的研究，如果我在课堂上，我不会使用这些检测器，因为检测器的准确率范围太大，如果我把检测器生成的百分比放在高风险的作业上，我不认为这能提供公平的评分。所以，有趣的是，那些正在生成或开发生成式
AI technology is also generating the AI detectors at the same time. And I wonder about about that fact. You know, faculty often say, I can tell when a student has used AI. And I don't believe that there's evidence to date that shows that faculty are very good at differentiating papers written by their students. students versus AI. I will say that if you're in a small classroom and you know your students writing skills and you have trends in their assignments and you know their voice, then yes, you are much better at detecting whether or not the paper was written by AI versus the student. But when you
人工智能技术的人，同时也正在生成人工智能检测器。我对这个事实感到好奇。你知道，教职员工经常说，我能看出学生什么时候使用了人工智能。我不认为迄今为止有证据表明，教职员工在区分学生自己写的论文和人工智能写的论文方面非常擅长。我想说的是，如果你在一个小班级里，你了解学生的写作技巧，并且你掌握了他们作业的趋势，了解他们的文风，那么是的，你确实能更好地检测出论文是由人工智能还是学生写的。但当你
go to the larger classrooms, which many of our colleagues are in classrooms with 200 students and they have writing assignments, then that becomes a much more challenging issue. But I've just, Just to summarize, again, I don't believe that AI detectors are at the point where I would comfortably use them to differentiate AI written work versus student work. Yeah, they're definitely not smoking gun evidence of students cheating. I mean, at best, you might use it as one data point among other points of triangulation, such as, as Beth was describing, knowing the student's voice, like, this really doesn't sound like this student. But, you know, sometimes even that doesn't give you the evidence that you
进入大班级时，我们的许多同事所在的班级有200名学生，他们有写作作业，那么这就成了一个更具挑战性的问题。但总而言之，我仍然认为人工智能检测器还没有达到我可以放心地用它们来区分人工智能生成的作品和学生作品的程度。是的，它们绝对不是学生作弊的铁证。我的意思是，充其量，你可能把它作为三角测量法中的一个数据点，正如贝丝所描述的那样，了解学生的文风，比如，这听起来真的不像这个学生写的。但是，你知道，有时即使是这样也无法给你提供你
think that it is. I had one student tell me that they were accused of using AI. And she said that the reason her work was so much better was that where she works, they were doing inventory over the weekend. And she usually works 16 to 20 hours on the weekend. So she had this one weekend where she had all day, both days. And so she was able to do really her best work. And so she turned in her best work. then the faculty member was like, well, this doesn't sound like your papers from earlier in the semester. You must be using AI. And the AI detector had flagged certain elements of it. So the student had to, when they had the actual, I guess, case heard on campus, her boss came in and said,
认为的那种证据。我有一个学生告诉我，她被指控使用人工智能。她说她的作品之所以好得多，是因为在她工作的地方，他们周末在做库存盘点。她通常在周末工作16到20个小时。所以她有一个周末，两天全天都有空。因此，她能够真正发挥出她最好的水平。所以她提交了她最好的作品。然后教职员工就说，嗯，这听起来不像你学期早些时候的论文。你一定是在使用人工智能。而且人工智能检测器标记了其中的某些元素。所以当他们在校园里举行听证会时，她的老板来了，说，
yeah, she was off that weekend. And she usually works every other weekend. And so she was able to win the case. But that's kind of a harrowing experience for students to go through. And I actually had another student in the focus group shared late last year that, whenever I finish writing a paper, if I think that it sounds too smart, I'll go back and dumb it down a bit so that my professor won't think it was produced by AI. And I just found that heartbreaking. That's not a skill you need in the real world is to dumb down your best
是的，那个周末她休息。她通常每隔一个周末工作。所以她赢得了这场官司。但这对学生来说是一种令人痛苦的经历。去年年底，我在焦点小组中还有另一位学生分享说，每当我写完一篇论文，如果我觉得它听起来太聪明了，我就会回去把它写得笨一点，这样我的教授就不会认为它是人工智能生成的。我发现这令人心碎。在现实世界中，你不需要那种把最好的作品写得笨一点的技能。
work. You know, that's not something we want to promote. But some students are indeed trying to walk that line to prevent themselves of being suspected of having, being used AI. There was also an interesting story that I heard about a student who was accused of using AI. There was a percentage that was generated for the paper that they turned in. And they took the faculty members work, something that the faculty member did, and put it into an AI generator and then provided for the faculty member a percentage of that work that was detected as AI generated as evidence of the purity of those types of detectors. I just thought that was ingenious.
你知道，这不是我们想要提倡的。但有些学生确实在试图走那条钢丝，以防止自己被怀疑使用了人工智能。我还听过一个有趣的故事，关于一个被指控使用人工智能的学生。他们提交的论文生成了一个百分比。他们拿了教职员工的作品，即教职员工自己做的一些东西，放进人工智能生成器中，然后向教职员工提供了该作品被检测为人工智能生成的百分比，以此作为这些检测器纯度的证据。我觉得这太天才了。
That's great. Yeah. You had a book teaching with AI. We documented a case exactly like that where they went to the Honor Court meeting and they took the professor's last single-authored paper prior to November 2022 and ran it through one of those AI detectors tools. And sure enough, it was flagged as being 33% AI generated before generative AI existed.
那太棒了。是的。你有一本关于用人工智能教学的书。我们记录了一个完全一样的案例，他们去了荣誉法庭会议，拿出了教授在2022年11月之前最后发表的单作者论文，并将其通过了其中一种人工智能检测工具。果然，在生成式人工智能存在之前，它就被标记为33%由人工智能生成。
So yeah, I think it's probably, you know, if you're going to use a gen AI detector, maybe run some of your own work through it and that might give you pause before you would actually bring that to your classroom. Is there an age below which you think students shouldn't be using AI at all? So I would say that as is true in any kind of a learning environment, it just has to be age appropriate or developmentally appropriate when you introduce any type of technology or technique. And for younger students, you have to be really careful and aware of protecting learning, making sure that students, particularly younger students, you're not outsourcing the learning
所以是的，我想，如果你打算使用生成式人工智能检测器，也许先用你自己的作品测试一下，这可能会让你在真正把它带到课堂之前三思而后行。你认为学生在多大年龄之前根本不应该使用人工智能？所以我会说，正如在任何学习环境中一样，当你引入任何类型的技术或技巧时，它必须是适合年龄或适合发展的。对于年龄较小的学生，你必须非常小心，并意识到要保护学习，确保学生，特别是年龄较小的学生，不会外包
of basic reading skills or writing skills or mathematical skills or reasoning because you want to build those foundational thinking skills, right? So teaching. But at the same, but at the same time, you want to start to introduce, if you can, an understanding of what AI is, but at a very basic awareness level when it comes to elementary school. And then as when you start to look at middle school, you can look more at the guided use, teach the guided use of AI, where students can begin to learn how AI can give answers, but why the answers can be wrong or biased. And how how you can compare AI output to what are considered trusted resources for middle schools. You know, the emphasis for middle school should probably be more on the curiosity and safety
基础阅读技能、写作技能、数学技能或推理技能的学习，因为你需要建立那些基础的思维技能，对吧？所以教学。但同时，如果你能的话，你想要开始引入对人工智能是什么的理解，但在小学阶段，这只是一个非常基础的认知水平。然后当你开始关注初中时，你可以更多地关注引导式使用，教授人工智能的引导式使用，学生可以开始学习人工智能如何提供答案，但为什么答案可能是错误的或有偏见的。以及你如何将人工智能的输出与被认为是初中可信的资源进行比较。你知道，初中的重点可能应该更多地放在好奇心和安全
and responsible habit use of AI, not the nitty, gritty how AI works. But then when you start to get to the high school level and even higher ed, there's more the critical and ethical use of AI. So it just develops over time. and I'm higher at, it's more the advanced and workforce-oriented may be used. How does this transfer to the workforce when I'm in the college classroom and I'm learning how to use AI? How will this work when I've graduated?
以及负责任地使用人工智能的习惯上，而不是人工智能如何工作的细节。但当你开始进入高中甚至高等教育阶段时，更多的是关于人工智能的批判性和伦理使用。所以它随着时间的推移而发展。而在高等教育中，更多的是高级和面向劳动力的使用。这如何转化为劳动力市场？当我在大学课堂上学习如何使用人工智能时，当我毕业后，这将如何运作？
So it's all about being age-appropriate. But I think we're going to learn over time as educators start to learn how to incorporate AI into the classroom. What is age-appropriate and what is the appropriate people? pieces to incorporate from a very early age. Well, just to wrap up, what are the big questions you're trying to answer? What are you each working on in this area right now? Dr. Schwartz, you want to take that first?
所以这一切都是关于适合年龄的。但我认为随着教育工作者开始学习如何将人工智能纳入课堂，我们会随着时间的推移而学习到什么是适合年龄的，以及从很小的时候开始纳入哪些部分是合适的。那么，总结一下，你们试图回答的重大问题是什么？你们每个人现在在这个领域正在研究什么？施瓦茨博士，你想先说吗？
Yeah, well, at APA, a lot of what we're looking at is, well, one of the collaborations at APA and and AC, and you is going to start later this year is helping faculty to answer some of these questions and conduct some scholarship on teaching and learning, which means, like, what are they answers questions that they have, and how can they go about critically evaluating what it means to use AI and its impact on learning? So part of our efforts is teaching faculty to ask those right questions and figure out the methodology to answer them and to really fill the gap in the literature that exists when it comes to understanding AI's impact on learning. Because When you look at AI research to date, it's often, it's not long-term learning, so we know
是的，在APA，我们关注的很多事情是，嗯，APA和AAC&U在今年晚些时候将开始的一项合作，是帮助教职员工回答其中一些问题，并进行一些关于教学和学习的学术研究，这意味着，比如，他们有什么答案问题，他们如何能够批判性地评估使用人工智能及其对学习的影响意味着什么？所以我们努力的一部分是教导教职员工提出那些正确的问题，并找出回答这些问题的方法，并真正填补在理解人工智能对学习的影响方面存在的文献空白。因为当你审视迄今为止的人工智能研究时，它通常不是长期的学习，所以我们知道
more about short-term performance than we know about long-term learning. They're often quiz scores and assignment scores, but it's not retention over weeks or months later. Like that, I'm just not finding them. Many of the research these days focuses on perceptions and people's opinions rather than on learning, so that's why filling the gap in the literature will be so important. And most studies to date don't really isolate the cause and the effect, you know, the generative AI to the learning that's taken place. And so we don't know whether it's the fact that AI is creating better feedback or more
短期表现比我们了解长期学习要多。它们通常是测验分数和作业分数，但不是几周或几个月后的保留率。像那样，我只是找不到它们。如今许多研究集中在感知和人们的观点上，而不是学习上，这就是为什么填补文献空白将如此重要。而且迄今为止的大多数研究并没有真正隔离因果关系，你知道，生成式人工智能对所发生的学习的影响。所以我们不知道是因为人工智能创造了更好的反馈还是更多的
practice opportunities or is it more time on the task. Some of those questions on psychological science we ask when it comes to what is leading to the connection between using a certain type of learning tool and the learning that's taking place. And as I said earlier, it's heavily concentrated in higher ed, so we really need to help and support educators for the younger students to figure out how to really start to assess how AI would impact learning for elementary and secondary schools. And Dr. Watson, what's ahead for you? You struggling to update your book. You have to do another another edition every six months.
练习机会，还是因为在任务上花费了更多时间。当我们谈论什么导致了使用某种学习工具与所发生的学习之间的联系时，我们在心理科学上会问其中一些问题。正如我之前所说，它高度集中在高等教育中，所以我们真的需要帮助和支持年轻学生的教育工作者，找出如何真正开始评估人工智能将如何影响小学和中学的学习。沃森博士，你未来有什么计划？你是否在努力更新你的书？你必须每六个月做另一个版本。
About every 18. Oh, wow. The rhythm that we're on. I guess the other thing that I'm really focused on these days is actually larger curricular structures. Like, you know, if we are incorporating AI literacy as a learning outcome, maybe as essential learning for college students, well, what do we actually teach them? And then what would be the compass for that?
大约每18个月。哦，哇。我们所处的节奏。我想我最近真正关注的另一件事实际上是更大的课程结构。比如，你知道，如果我们把人工智能素养作为一种学习成果，也许作为大学生的基本学习内容，那么我们实际上教他们什么？然后那将是什么指南？
I mean, certainly what the world of work demands would be a component of that. but then there's also sort of other moral, ethical, civic responsibilities as well that we would want to incorporate into that definition. But, you know, as you look at some of the AI literacy frameworks that have emerged, almost all of them predate agentic AI. And as we think about the world of work, there's a lot of shifts that are taking place. I was literally just talking to a friend last week who was at a, they're in sales and they were at a sales meeting. they learned that all of the support staff around the core sales team was going to be laid off before the end of the year. And the expectation was that they would begin using agentic AI to actually do a lot of those
我的意思是，当然，工作世界的需求将是其中的一个组成部分。但还有其他道德、伦理、公民责任，我们也希望将其纳入该定义中。但是，你知道，当你审视一些已经出现的人工智能素养框架时，几乎所有这些框架都早于代理人工智能。当我们思考工作世界时，正在发生很多转变。我上周刚和一个朋友谈过，他们在销售部门，他们参加了一个销售会议。他们得知核心销售团队周围的所有支持人员将在年底前被裁员。而期望是他们将开始使用代理人工智能来实际完成许多那些
discrete tasks that require some level of decision making that these more entry level positions were doing. So managing agentic AI, managing agents, you know, that's a different skill set that I had seen in any of the earlier models because it really agentic AI really was a present at that point. So there's this evolution of what is AI literacy. And, you know, one thing that we do well in higher ed is curriculum reform. One thing that we don't do well is curriculum reform fast. And the truth is, the target is changing quite quickly these days. So staying on top of that, you know, going through doing all of the processes that we always do to ensure quality and
需要一定程度决策能力的离散任务，而这些任务以前是由这些入门级职位完成的。所以管理代理人工智能，管理代理，你知道，那是我在任何早期模型中都没有见过的不同技能组合，因为它确实，代理人工智能在那个时候确实存在。所以人工智能素养是什么，存在这种演变。而且，你知道，我们在高等教育中做得好的一件事是课程改革。我们做得不好的一件事是快速的课程改革。事实是，目标这些天变化得非常快。所以保持领先，你知道，经历我们总是做的所有流程以确保质量和
an accuracy for the components of a learning outcome that we would then engender into our curriculum or into our major. We still need to be doing that work. But I think what's really needed of higher ed is a new kind of agility. How do we do this work more quickly and recursively? Like gen ed reform is maybe the biggest curricular reform effort that a campus can do. And on many campuses, they do gen ed reform every 10 to 20 years because it is such a, It takes a year to do, right. Right, exactly. And so how do we shorten that time frame for curriculum reform in service to a learning outcome that is shifting rapidly?
学习成果组成部分的准确性，然后我们将这些成果纳入我们的课程或专业。我们仍然需要做这项工作。但我认为高等教育真正需要的是一种新的敏捷性。我们如何更快速、更递归地完成这项工作？比如通识教育改革可能是校园能做的最大的课程改革努力。在许多校园里，他们每10到20年进行一次通识教育改革，因为它是一个，它需要一年时间来完成，对吧。对，完全正确。那么我们如何缩短课程改革的时间框架，以服务于正在迅速转变的学习成果？
You know, you don't build something into the curriculum and then you don't change it for five years where we see the rate of change around AI is exceptionally fast. So that whole challenge of institutional change, agility, curricular agility, and the evolution of what AI literacy means to the population of students that we have and that will soon be beyond our campuses. Those are among the key things that I think about these days. And I'll just add one more thing. And my role from APA's perspective or from my own perspective is that we have this foundational learning science, foundational principles that we know leads to strong learning. And we have to keep that in mind when we're reconsidering the assignments
你知道，你不会把某样东西构建到课程中，然后五年不改变它，因为我们看到围绕人工智能的变化速度是非常快的。所以制度变革、敏捷性、课程敏捷性，以及人工智能素养对我们拥有的学生群体以及很快将超出我们校园的学生群体意味着什么的演变，这些都是我最近思考的关键问题。我还要补充一点。从APA的角度或我自己的角度来看，我的角色是，我们拥有这种基础学习科学，我们知道导致强大学习的基础原则。当我们重新考虑作业时，我们必须记住这一点
and what we're having students do because we know what leads to a student understanding, a student remembering, a student moving forward with that information in mind. If we don't keep that in mind, then we're just missing out on this important part of the scientific literature from psychology that can really provide a lot of answers. Well, Dr. Schwartz, Dr. Watson, I want to thank you both for joining me. I think you're doing really important work right now. Thanks for having us. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website at speakingofpsychology.org
以及我们让学生做什么，因为我们知道什么会导致学生理解、学生记忆、学生带着这些信息向前迈进。如果我们不记住这一点，那么我们就错过了心理学科学文献中这一重要的部分，它可以真正提供很多答案。好吧，施瓦茨博士，沃森博士，我要感谢你们两位加入我。我认为你们现在正在做非常重要的工作。谢谢你们邀请我们。你可以在我们的网站speakingofpsychology.org上找到《心理学谈话》之前的剧集
or on Apple, Spotify, YouTube, or wherever you get your podcasts. And if you like what you've heard, please subscribe and leave a safe review. If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, you can email us at speakingof psychology at APA.org. Speaking of psychology is produced by Lee Weinerman. Thank you for listening for the American Psychological Association. I'm Kim Mills. Thank you. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
或者在Apple、Spotify、YouTube或任何你获取播客的地方。如果你喜欢你所听到的，请订阅并留下一个安全的评论。如果你对未来的播客有评论或想法，你可以发送电子邮件至speakingofpsychology@APA.org。《心理学谈话》由李·温纳曼制作。感谢收听美国心理学会的节目。我是金·米尔斯。谢谢。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。